this episode of real science is brought
to you by curiosity stream sign up today
at curiosity stream comm slash real
science and get free access to watch
nebula calm in this mess that is our
current world there is so much
information coming at us about what is
or isn't an effective treatment against
the corona virus hydroxychloroquine for
example first praised based on a small
questionable study then debunked as
being ineffective and now being praised
again based on another criticized study
medicine shouldn't be politicized but
that is what's happening and it's so
hard to know what's true and what is
nonsense
so when headlines broke recently about
another potential corona virus treatment
it's understandable if your immediate
reaction with skepticism mine certainly
was the treatment dexamethasone is a
common corticosteroid and it's being
hailed as the biggest breakthrough so
far in corona virus treatment scientists
are saying the results of a recent
clinical trial are astounding and are
saying the importance of the findings
can't be overstated it's cheap it's
readily available and reports are saying
that it could drastically decrease
corona virus deaths so is this actually
the start of a new chapter in corona
virus treatment as the headlines say how
could it be that a humble common steroid
can outperform every other treatment
that has been tested so far treating
viral infections is not straightforward
a virus is difficult to kill because
it's not alive to begin with bacterial
infections can be fought with
antibiotics which attacked the bacterial
cell walls block protein production and
stop bacteria from reproducing breaking
down the elements that give them life
but antibiotics aren't effective against
viral infections because viruses don't
carry out any of those processes on
their own instead they hijack a host
cells machinery forcing it to replicate
the viral genome and produce viral
proteins so medications that aim to
treat viral infections aim to stop the
virus from being able to hijack the host
machinery preventing it from replicating
rym Desa fear the antiviral being used
against the coronavirus works by
blocking polymerase from making new
strands of RNA REM Desa fear is a
molecule very similar to adenine if it
is present the polymerase enzyme may
accidentally place it in the sequence
instead of adenine which terminates the
strand but antivirals are challenging to
develop they need to be tailored to work
for each specific virus it's also
difficult to find drugs that interfere
with viral replication without also
harming the host cell also because they
don't deactivate or destroy the virus
all they can do is prevent the viral
load from increasing to a point where it
causes illness so antivirals can be used
to manage a viral infection but can't
completely get rid of it it took decades
for antivirals to be developed to the
point where they could manage diseases
like HIV and even still they are no cure
in the case of the corona virus room
dezerter has been shown to shorten the
amount of time that patients need to
spend in the hospital but it had no
statistically significant impact on
deaths but the virus itself is not the
only thing that makes a corona virus
infection deadly and deactivating it is
not the only way to treat the disease
the virus damages the body when it
hijacks human cells and subsequently
kills or damages them to release more
viral particles this cell damage can
certainly harm you and make you sick but
in the case of this corona virus the
people who are dying from the disease
don't usually die from the viral
infection itself if the virus migrates
to the airway as it does in symptomatic
cases of kovat 19 it begins to replicate
and invade lung cells and in particular
the lungs ciliated cells as these cells
begin to die they shed away and fill the
airway with debris and fluid during this
time the immune system kicks in immune
cells flock to the lungs to help clear
debris and repair lung tissue if
everything goes correctly the immune
response is limited to the infected
areas and tightly controlled but
sometimes the immune system gets kicked
into overdrive and can do way more harm
than good this
a reaction of the immune system is known
as a cytokine storm cytokines are
molecules that allow for the
communication between cells and usually
signal the immune system to start doing
its job but in a cytokine storm their
levels soar far beyond what's needed the
excess of cytokines attracts an excess
of immune cells such as lymphocytes and
neutrophils resulting in extreme
inflammation in the lungs in this
extreme inflammation can cause a lot of
damage it can lead to high fever leaky
blood vessels blood clotting and wreaks
general havoc on the body white blood
cells are misdirected to attack and
inflame even healthy tissues leading to
failure of the lungs heart liver and
kidneys in the worst cases it leads to a
condition called ARDS acute respiratory
distress syndrome blood oxygen levels
plummet and it becomes extremely hard to
breathe alveoli become completely full
of fluid many patients with ARDS end up
on ventilators and many die it has an
estimated mortality of approximately 40%
so sadly for most people who die of
kovat 19 it's not the virus itself that
kills but a disastrous overreaction of
their own immune system scientists
aren't sure exactly what causes some
people to be more susceptible to
cytokine storms than others but believe
it may have something to do with a
genetic mutation in some people and
pre-existing conditions in others it
also could be the reason why younger
people are less affected by the corona
virus as their immune systems are less
developed and may produce lower levels
of cytokines so in the absence of a
vaccine or a more effective antiviral
scientists and doctors are left trying
to treat the symptoms of the infection
to try to keep patients alive and this
is where dexamethasone the common
steroid is making waves in the headlines
it all started in the UK and one of the
biggest and most important scientific
studies going on in our lifetime the
recovery trial the recovery trial first
made headlines when it found that the
much-talked-about potential treatment
hydroxychloroquine had
benefits to patients hospitalized with
kovat 19 despite the hype now the
recovery trial is making headlines again
with a result that researchers did not
really expect that dexamethasone a
common steroid was hugely beneficial to
the most critically ill kovat 19
patients more beneficial than any of the
other numerous treatments that they have
been testing it cut deaths by about one
third in patients who are on ventilators
and by about one fifth in patients
receiving oxygen therapy but were not on
ventilators and while these numbers
imply that this drug can't save everyone
it is by far the most promising result
that researchers have found researchers
believe it works because steroids like
this are known to decrease inflammation
and suppress the immune system this is
also why it only works in the most
severe cases of kovat 19:00 where the
immune system has flared up to damaging
levels since steroids like this have
been known to decrease inflammation for
a long time it seems like maybe it
should have been obvious that something
like this would help but that is
definitely not the case steroids like
this were tried during the SARS and h1n1
epidemics but the results were
inconclusive with some data even saying
it would be harmful but the results from
the dexamethasone clinical trial are
promising and because of how robust the
study was when this research says
dexamethasone will save countless lives
we can trust it this is largely because
of the size of the trial
researchers enrolled 2,100 participants
who received dexamethasone at a low to
moderate dose for ten days and compared
how they fared against 4300 people who
received standard care and the results
showed not subtle improvement but highly
statistically significant improvement
for any of you stats people the p-values
and confidence intervals for the results
were very good
however treatment with dexamethasone is
not without its challenges when you
suppress an overactive immune system you
may also block a person's ability to
recover this is why it's important that
the drug isn't given in the early stage
of infection when the body needs its
full arsenal of immune action while the
full data is yet to be released
doctors have found the preliminary
results compelling enough to start using
it it is now a standard of care for
patients with severe kovat 19 in the UK
because it's not a new drug doctors are
confident they can give it to patients
while managing the risks and side
effects and for $10 for a course of
treatment it's hard to not see how this
drug will be hugely influential in the
fight against kovat 19 in stark contrast
Gilead Sciences just announced that they
will soon be charging over three
thousand dollars for a single course of
REM des aveer discovering that a cheap
readily available well known and well
studied drug is effective for the worst
cases of kovat 19 is a fantastic glimmer
of hope in an otherwise bleak crisis and
while this steroid is exciting news what
I'm most excited about is the existence
of the recovery trial itself it's the
largest trial being conducted for Kovan
19 anywhere it's adaptive design that
can evaluate half a dozen drugs at once
has already proven to be extremely
effective in making progress towards the
best coronavirus treatments their data
monitoring committee reviews results as
they come in allowing the trial to drop
any drugs that clearly don't work or
even add new ones it is more robust and
more nimble than one could have ever
expected in such a short time an
information like what they are gathering
that works towards eliminating the
speculation and politics from kovat 19
healthcare will be the way we end this
pandemic
I know that at this point all the
coronavirus news and updates can be
exhausting it's important to know what's
going on but equally important to switch
off from it all sometimes I definitely
go through cycles of wanting to
understand every new piece of
information that comes out and not
wanting to hear anyone utter the phrase
coronavirus for a week and for this
reason curiosity stream has been the
perfect place to satisfy either of my
moods if you're in a mood of wanting to
understand the treatments or vaccines
being developed
you should watch coronavirus combating
the outbreak on curiosity stream where
experts share the methods currently in
place to slow down this infectious
disease but if you are in a mood where
you can't bear one more single second of
coronavirus news than the new series
nigel Otto blow stuff up may be the
perfect antidote in the first episode he
explodes some potatoes and sausages with
electricity leading up to seeing what
similar shocks do to a human and
ultimately seeing if nigel can survive a
lightning bolt it's a really well made
series that is the perfect still
educational distraction from the news
and if you're a fan of educational
content and looking for more quality
things to watch right now then this is
the perfect time to sign up because a
subscription to curiosity stream now
comes with a subscription to nebula
nebula is a place where top educational
content creators like polyphonic
Wendover productions and our other
channel real engineering can create
videos freely without worrying about the
YouTube algorithm or D monetization it's
a place where we can upload our content
ad free and also experiment with
original content and new series the
original content is my favorite part of
nebula shows like real engineering
logistics of d-day series the last
episode was about the aerial landings
that made d-day possible and the next
one will be about the logistics of air
support so if you sign up for curiosity
stream at curiosity stream comm slash
real science you'll get a subscription
to curiosity stream and a subscription
to nebula for now just 1479 a year 26
percent off the usual price by signing
up you're not just supporting this
channel but all of your favorite
educational content creators
thanks for watching and if you would
like to see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter and patreon are below
you